[Musique]
bienvenue pour parler d'un sujet
absolument passionnante puisque on va
parler d'architecturé avec elisabeth
roger lefebvre bonjour bonjour vous êtes
la directrice du conseil d'architecturé
d'urbanisme et d'environnement des
yvelines le sait a eu eux vous êtes
architecte vous même déjà qu'est ce que
c'est de cae alors à quoi nous sommes
une association qui existe dans la
plupart des départements de france
au moment où la loi sur l'architecturé a
décidé de créer des structures de
conseil pour accompagner les
particuliers comme les élus sur ce sujet
primordial du cadre de vie donc nous
conseillons sur l'architecturé le
patrimoine le paysage tous les sujets
sur lesquels finalement personne n'a de
l'information habituellement mais c'est
vrai qu'il ya toujours peut-être parfois
un peu de padre distance bien peut-être
les jo sont peut-être un peu perdus
vis-à-vis des problèmes d'architecturé
et d'urbanisme donc vous pouvez les
conseillers voilà nous les recevons
aussi eun donc dans nos locaux comme
aujourd'hui à l'eau vous et où on est
basée à montigny-le-bretonneux tout près
du théâtre d'accord et tous les
mercredis par exemple nous recevons les
particuliers qui veulent un conseil sur
rendez vous ils ont la possibilité
d'être reçus par un architecte qui les
conseillent en amont de leur projet là
où l'intérêt de venir voir le sérieux
c'est vraiment toujours en amont donc
même les élus nous les conseillons aussi
sur leurs projets toujours au préalable
avant d'aller voir un architecte libéral
ou un urbaniste notre pays peuvent aller
voir bien sûr
notre intérêt c'est de les leur donner
le maximum d'ouverture par rapport au
paysage à l'urbanisme à l' architecture
et ensuite de les aider éventuellement à
trouver les bonnes personnes pour faire
leurs projets
quand ils ont bien débroussaillé donc il
faut courir comme valeur pratiquement
pour deux rendez vous voilà le pôle est
particulier c'est gratuit lorsque les
particuliers paie une taxe c'est la taxe
d'aménagement qui permet de financer le
csl conseil départemental qui fixe le
taux de cette taxe et qui nous le
reverse ensuite donc les particuliers
ont un conseil gratuit quand ils
viennent au cae et les élus également
peuvent nous demander des conseils alors
surplus le sur des sujets plus gros
évidemment plus basse soit
l'accompagnement de leur pays à l'ue
soit l'accompagnement de leurs projets
et on intervient
en ce moment on fait beaucoup de charte
architecturale et de promotion pour
aider à fluidifier les projets dans les
communes on a travaillé comme ça avec
viroflay saint germain en laye on vient
de terminer la charte d'orgeval le dire
quoi fluidifier des projets alors il ya
beaucoup de recours sur les projets
architecture et ça permet aussi aux
promoteurs de ne pas aller voir
directement les particuliers mais devoir
en premier les élus est de faire en
sorte que le projet soit mieux acceptées
par la population alors quant au lien
justement avec la population parliez de
de cet architecte
1er décembre ça hier le 2 décembre de
décembre nous recevons ici tous les
particuliers et les élus qui le
souhaitent on a une journée spéciale
adhérons qui permet de présenter
l'exposition que nous avons en ce moment
et qui tourne dans le département
peuvent et on va leur présenter sommet
de bangui et on va leur présenter aussi
toutes les actions que l'on peut mener
avec eux parce que aujourd'hui on a
l'obligation par exemple de réduire nos
consommations énergétiques
et à moins imperméabilisées réaliser des
îlots de fraîcheur
et tous ces sujets là on essaie de
sensibiliser les élus et les
particuliers surtout y arriver donc
le 2 dès le 2 décembre aussi on a un
webinaire avec l' agence locale de
l'énergie de saint quentin en yvelines à
18h sur l'accompagnement des architectes
sur la transformation des copropriétés
et la reine la réhabilitation
énergétique des copropriétés sujet très
compliqué actuellement webinaire ça veut
dire que si on peut pas exister on
dirait qu'on pourra le trouver sur votre
voilà sur notre site internet sur celui
de l'alec
peut-être une question sur
l'architecturé ce territoire
c'est-à-dire il ya une diversité
architecturale absolument incroyable en
séance à 22 environnement sa ricardo
bofill les mêmes a plus assez récent
ok comment vous le voyez ce territoire
architecturalement justement alors il
est comme vous dites très variés parce
qu'on a beaucoup et site de maisons
rurales qu'il faut ne pas abîmer donc on
a un rôle à la fois de sensibilisation
sur comment voir l' architecture comment
la comprendre donc par exemple sur un
vieux bâti ne pas faire de l'isolation
thermique par l'extérieur par exemple
donc on travaille beaucoup aussi avec
les architectes des bâtiments de france
qui protège certains secteurs mais qui
ne protège pas tout bien sûr donc notre
rôle aussi c'est de de faire comprendre
architecture de la sphère de la faire
découvrir de la faire aimer dans tous
ses aspects donc aussi bien l'
architecture contemporaine la faire
comprendre aussi pourquoi
réalise des balcons et on a l'obligation
de mettre beaucoup plus de verdure aussi
d'ouverture l'ouverture est pourquoi les
balcons alors par exemple on a bien vu
qu'avec le confinement ça n'avait besoin
de l'espace extérieur donc alors que
dans un bâti rural on avait un jardin
dans un immeuble par exemple avoir
beaucoup plus d'espacés extérieurs liés
au logement est vraiment important c'est
d'abord qu'est-ce qui a changé justement
dans
l'architecturé de l'urbanisme jeudi
justement conseil d'architecturé
d'urbanisme et d'environnement et on l'a
rajouté ya pas si longtemps l'on
revienne à mon nom des lieux dès le
début dès le début la loi sur
l'architecturé de 1977 a créé les cae et
dès le début on avait ces trois mots
trois lectures urbanisme environnement
alors l'environnement à cette époque qui
étaient plus considérés par les ceo dans
le sens du paysage et puis petit à petit
on a évolué et le paysage est toujours
extrêmement présent mais maintenant
c'est l'écologie qui prend plus de peur
enfin une part importante dans notre
travail pour aller vers le facteur 4
vous savez qu'aujourd'hui on doit en
2050 réduire par quatre nos émissions de
gaz à effet de serre donc le travail sur
la réhabilitation du bâtiment des
bâtiments pour réduire l'énergie qui le
fil alors l'énergie qu'il colle on doit
utiliser pour les fabriquer mais aussi
l'énergie que l'on doit utiliser pour
les entrées de bourg dont il n'est
utilisé
oui donc ça faut réduire ça mais il ya
des architectes pour s'arrêter ricciotti
nous sommes par exemple
qui avait fait des pamphlets sur la
haute qualité environnementale hqe eux
ces normes la aux dix ans finalement ça
réduit et la créativité des architectes
est ce que t'as pas l'impression qu'on
fait un peu partout la même chose alors
effectivement
d'une certaine manière malheureusement
on stéréotypes un peul architecture vous
avez raison nous notre travail justement
c'est de montrer les spécificités de
chaque lieu est de faire en sorte dans
les chartes architectural par exemple
que l'on est rien avec des ateliers avec
des habitants avec les élus donc tout le
monde autour de la table réfléchi
ensemble un aux spécificités de la
commune pour faire en sorte que les
projets futurs soient les mieux intégrés
donc quand on est dans un centre ancien
très patrimoniale on essaie de faire de
l' architecture qui soit en complément
de cette architecture et qu'ils ne
viennent pas heurter les mais l'
architecture c'est toujours soit en
continuité son opposition donc
l'opposition peut être intéressante à la
condition que on
la comprennent et donc notre rôle aussi
c'est d'expliquer larchitecture alors on
va parler un peu de cette exposition
donc transformé le bâti est alors les
cdt regarder le présent et préparer
l'avenir c'est
transformé le bâti c'est à dire que en
effet on a dans dans des villages des
anciennes bâtisses qu'il faut soit
rénové soient transformés qu'il faut
parfois surélevé ans et c'est tout ça
voilà c'est tous ces sujets et ce sont
aussi les sujets des particuliers qui
viennent des particuliers ou des hulu
des écus élus absolue mais les
particuliers c'est vraiment un sujet
pour eux très importants avoirs plutôt
que de déménager à voir une pièce en
plus par exemple donc cette exposition
monde des petits projets ou des plus
gros mais plutôt des petits qui permet
qui permettent de sensibiliser les
personnes en dire ça ça a été fait par
quelqu'un d'autre donc vous pouvez y
arriver d'accord vous pouvez vous pouvez
aussi le faire et on montre aussi des
projets de collectivités qui ont
transformé un bâti plutôt que de le
démolir aujourd'hui on se dit que
démolir ça demande énormément d'énergie
parce que il faut calculer un coût
global si on calcule en coût global il
est plus intéressant de conserver et de
transformer oui parce que il faut
considérer le terrain qui a été acheté
au départ le batik a été créé le betty
qui va être qu'on va être obligé de
démolir plus toute l'énergie qu'on va
mettre à réfléchir à un nouveau projet
plus l'énergie qu'on va mettre pour
construire un nouveau donc quand on
compte tous un plus
ce qu'on ne compte jamais c'est le coût
social de la démolition c'est à dire
toute la willaya
exactement donc on montre aussi des
petits projets qui ont été faits dans
des mairies avec nous on a accompagné et
notamment un petit une petite grange à
moisson qui a été transformée en musée
qui est très très chouette parce que
l'architecturé est très bien inséré
l'atelier 15 qui est l'architecte qui a
réalisé cette petite opération la très
bien
transformé par rapport à l'architecturé
du village on n'est pas en opposition là
on est complètement en poursuite mais de
manière contemporaine avec l'
architecture du village de ça c'est le
mélange aussi entre un bon et je veux
pas ce qu'on va faire on va mettre par
exemple ce petit film parce que ces
films on peut les voir sur votre site un
oui
il va y avoir treize films voilà équipe
qui présentent chacune des chacun des 13
projets qui sont présentés dans
l'exposition et je vous propose qu'on
met sur le sur le net deux sur notre
site ce film sur la rénovation de deux
mois sans
s'aimer c'est passionnant et donc ça
évidemment ça concerne à la fois les
élus des villes des mères est à la fois
les particuliers voilà c'est la ccit je
veux rajouter un étage chez moi c'est ça
voilà rajouter un étage à buc c'est une
petite maison toute simple mais qu'ils
avaient du caractère et on l'a surélevée
et tout à coup elle prend une autre
dimension et et elle est tout à fait
contemporaine dans sa deuxième lit ouais
et les bâtis anciens finalement on peut
les transformer pour qu'ils soient aux
normes
de bien sûr bien sûr alors soit moins de
dépenses énergétiques alors souvent dans
le bâti ancien on essaie de rénover par
l'intérieur de réhab la fin de d'isoler
par l'intérieur mais on a aussi des
techniques notamment dans les beaux
bâtiments à plusieurs étages dans les
centres anciens on a des techniques
maintenant d'isolation en béton de
chanvre par exemple qui permettent
d'isoler notamment les cours intérieures
d'accord est ce que quand on a une
façade en pierre on ne peut pas à la
rénover avec une isolation thermique par
l'extérieur en revanche la cour
intérieure qui a peut-être un peu moins
de qualité architecturale
oui on l'isolé avec des bétons de
chanvre et d'autres techniques y sont
très intéressantes mais ça tout ça on
peut le voir dans cette émission dans
cette exposition pardon et puis aussi
sur le vôtre si droit sur votre si tôt
on voit les films noter l'exposition à
laquelle on peut venir alors on peut la
voir au sérieux mais on peut aussi la
prêter dans toutes les communes qui ont
adhérence que certains voient là
itinérante elle vient d'aller pendant un
mois à montesson et en ce moment elle
est aussi un lieu de la gironde qui nous
l'a proposé parce que entre ses yeux on
collabore aussi et on s'entraide les uns
les autres coder merci infiniment on va
se revoir très vite parce qu'on va
peut-être faire des émissions
récurrentes sur l'architecturé parce que
ils leur disent oui évidemment parce que
ce sont des sujets absolument
passionnant merci beaucoup elisabeth
roja lefebvre merci beaucoup pour votre
soutien à nos actions
[Musique]